SECURITY, AN ISSUE OF U.S.
SOVEREIGNTY.
MEXICO NEEDS TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, IT IS TIME FOR
THE WALL TO BE BUILT ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
JOINING US NOW, COUNSEL TO THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, KELLYANNE
CONWAY.
I WOULD BE NEGLIGENT, I REALLY
DON'T WANT TO DIGNIFY THIS
RIDICULOUS DINNER, BUT I THINK I
WOULD BE NEGLIGENT IF I DIDN'T
ASK YOUR THOUGHTS.
I REALLY, TRULY -- IT IS SO
INSULTING AND CRUDE AND I TRY
AND ALWAYS SPLIT THE TABLES, IF
IT IS WITH A CONSERVATIVE
COMEDIAN SAYING THIS ABOUT ANY
LIBERAL WOMAN, WHAT WITH THE
RESULTS BE?
>> SEAN, IN SOME WAYS, IT WAS
VERY LITTLE THAT WAS SURPRISING
ON SATURDAY NIGHT, THOUGH, SO
OUTRAGE FROM SOME PEOPLE WHO
LOOKED DOWN AT TWITTER ALL DAY
LONG AND SEE THE LIKES OF SARAH
AND IVANKA, V, INSULTED.
THIS JUST HAPPENED RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THEM WHERE THEY WERE
ALL GUSSIED UP SO THEY COULDN'T
DENY IT.
IN SOME WAYS, IT WAS JUST
ANOTHER DAY AT THE OFFICE.
THEY KNEW THEY WERE INSULTED
HANDILY.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SOME PEOPLE AND
BE MISERABLE OR US ANY LESS
POWERFUL.
AND BEAUTIFUL TO THE JOBS THAT
WE HAVE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTRY
THAT WE LOVE.
I ACTUALLY THINK BOTH EVENTS
SATURDAY NIGHT REALLY HELPED
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FIRST HE GOT TO GO TO MICHIGAN
AND TELL -- HE WAS IN
WASHINGTON, MICHIGAN, TOUTING
THE ECONOMIC PROGRESS, THE
HISTORIC NATURE OF WHAT'S GOING
ON IN KOREA, AND THEN THE EVENT
HERE IN WASHINGTON, IT HELPED
THEM AS WELL, BECAUSE IT FED
RIGHT INTO ALL OF THE CYNICISM,
THE SKEPTICISM THAT A LOT OF
AMERICANS HAVE ABOUT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA WRIT LARGE.
THEY HAVE A -- LET ME SAY
SOMETHING.
I SPENT TONIGHT TRYING TO FIND
OUT HOW MUCH MICHELLE WOLF WAS
PAID.
NOBODY WILL GIVE ME A STRAIGHT
ANSWER.
I CALLED THREE PEOPLE WHO WERE
ON THE DAIS, WHO ACTUALLY PICKED
UP THE PHONE, AND NO ONE WOULD
GIVE ME AN ANSWER.
THEY SAID, THEY HAD NO IDEA.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
ABOUT THE ANCHORS AND REPORTERS
FINANCIAL HOLDINGS, TOO,
CONSIDERING EVERY VOTING CARES
ABOUT MINE.
>> HOLD ON.
THE REASON I AM SAID THIS, WE
ARE TOLD THIS IS A SCHOLARSHIP
DINNER, AND YOU SHOULD PAY FOR
YOUR ENTERTAINMENT, BUT I FEEL
REALLY BADLY FOR THE STUDENTS.
THE PRESIDENT, VICE PRESIDENT
MET THEM AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
THEY TAKE PICTURES WITH THEM THE
OTHER DAY, I HAD OCCASION TO SEE
ME SCHOLARSHIP WINNERS, I FEEL
SORRY FOR THEM, BECAUSE THEY
WERE ALMOST AN AFTERTHOUGHT THAT
NIGHT.
I DON'T WANT ANYBODY TO SAY THIS
WAS ABOUT THEM, THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION STOOD UP AND SAID,
AN ATTACK ON ONE JOURNALIST IS
AN ATTACK ON ALL JOURNALISTS,
WELL, FOLKS, THINK ABOUT THIS.
AS AN ATTACK ON ONE WOMAN OR TWO
WOMEN AN ATTACK ON ALL WOMEN?
>> Sean: I'M GLAD I DIDN'T
INTERRUPT YOU.
THAT'S A POWERFUL LINE.
NORTH KOREA, HISTORY IN THE
MAKING.
NO ONE SAW COMING.
IRAN'S INTELLIGENCE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
THE UNPRECEDENTED ALLIANCE,
ISRAEL, UNITED STATES, THE
SAUDIS, JORDANIANS, EGYPTIANS,
THE EMIRATES.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE WHAT PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH CAN DO.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S INCREDIBLE, SEAN, AND IT IS
URGENTLY OWING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP LEADERSHIP AND
HIS VISION.
AND ALSO HIS PATIENTS.
THE RELATIONSHIPS THAT HE'S BEEN
ABLE TO BUILD WITH LEADERS
ACROSS THE WORLD IN THE FIRST 15
MONTHS OF HIS ADMINISTRATION,
THE FIRST YEAR AND A HALF SINCE
HE WAS ELECTED, HAS LED US TO
THIS MOMENT AND FOLKS DON'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE POWER OF
NORTH KOREA AND SOUTH KOREA
REALLY COMING TOGETHER HOLDING
HANDS AND SAYING THAT DECADES OF
WAR WILL -- COULD JUST BE SWEPT
AWAY, COULD END, ALSO,
NORTH KOREA HAS AGREED TO STOP
DOING ITS NUCLEAR TESTS TO ALLOW
INSPECTORS IN, WHICH IS KEY, TO
GO BACK TO THE SAME TIME ZONE AS
SOUTH KOREA, A LOT OF PROGRESS
THERE, AND ITS DONALD TRUMP
LEADERSHIP.
MANY CRITICS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE GIVING HIM
THE CREDIT FOR THAT.
>> Sean: THESE ARE AMAZING
TIMES.